what did your friends think of Bobby
honestly honestly I want the honest
truth they they said that you were the
most disrespectful person that they have
ever seen which is interesting to me
because I liked it
disrespectful in one way
Taki you you real attacky Attack Mode
condescending yeah I talked about attack
mode yeah yeah you're like uh you know I
apologize fighter to to them not me you
know what
I want your whole family and all your
friends
that's my goal in life now is for them
to like me no yeah
I'm gonna try I've been trying to do
that you can't win or no I know but but
you know what I can though is soften it
right because the blows so let me ask
you something this all right they don't
like me
they're trying to figure it out
so political
so that pause right
that pause right there was what I call
an eternity
a whole lifetime in that little pause
that was the most painful pause I've
ever heard of my life okay yeah so
basically they don't like me so so it's
okay it's fine not everyone's gonna like
not my immediate family they're good no
I you're out yeah yeah yeah I want the
cool kids to like Max one of them no no
no no match Holloway yeah you know
because maybe you pissed Max off too no
I never did you did have something to
say about Max the last time oh yeah so
maybe that's why he's not doing it what
did I say you okanasi would beat him up
yeah
I never said that remember when you read
my mind I never said that
I'm a huge I think Max Holloway is the
greatest Striker boxer that the MMA
world has ever seen I agree he's a
machine clip that he's gonna send it to
Max game yeah no I really no I really
believe that and I think that um he's
one of my top three of all time of all
time I think that um that that match he
did with Carter cater cater yeah right
yeah was just a demonstration of pure
talent and god-given skill I mean it's
just what a Works what a great job okay
okay so max doesn't hate you thank you
your other friendship and like but but
what they were saying is because I was
making fun of you
yeah but
but I was telling the truth no hey
subjective it's subjective of truth
right no no
it's subjective subjective right I mean
it but they're they're sensitive right
oh okay yeah yeah all right so let me
talk about that sensitivity okay okay
yeah guess who the most sensitive person
in this room is
you I am I'm the most sensitive person
in this room and the reason I attack and
the reason why I I get in front of it is
because I don't want to get hurt okay
okay but at the end of the day if you
called me and said
like who is this who's uh who are you
imitating oh
oh
Bobby yo okay
his name a couple of times
uh who is this they have your comings
where China it's a little bit
anyway if you needed something I would
be there for you so that's all
appreciate that I want to say it but
just on this in this podcasting um
medium I I attack and you know what I've
been watching myself lately and I go you
know I don't like the way I do it
you know I've seen a couple of Clips
where I'm like I'm a little too
aggressive and you know what I'm
learning from you so this podcast no
attack
all love no yeah guy it's it's whatever
it's got you're not [__]
all right you know what I re since
you've said that I was really pondering
at home
why were you questioning yourself I went
back into my elementary coloring books
and I said you really couldn't draw on
the Lions I I was like forget my really
yeah you know if there's something so
and also I think you're very handsome
you know what you know what Bobby I can
say this with um pure confidence
um each week that passes by
this this teeth that you see just gets
straighter and straighter because you
have after there's a lot of Invisalign
oh after you bought Invisalign yeah
after 39 weeks in brother it looks great
you know that's what I've been noticing
about you yeah yeah you know it's done
it's horse-like yeah that's why yeah
yeah no somebody tried to book me for um
it's a they thought they thought I was
trying to like impersonate freaking
Queen
and asked if I could like perform yeah
yeah I don't even know his songs oh so I
just look like him did I make fun of you
about that last time I called you
Freddie Mercury yeah yeah you didn't
know who that was what yeah you didn't
know and he didn't know what it was you
know and that's what's endearing about
you though you know let me ask you some
some trivia if you if I may oh 100 with
music right yeah let's let's go sci-fi